and today was the big day we finally got
the news there it is check it out
uh it is it is kamala harris we have
this amazing portrait of kamala
she is having a good old time in this
image this is a meme by the way i don't
know people who
people are just listening can't see you
but what is that what is that picture
from though on the bottom right
i don't know is that is that like a real
image i think so
which is kind of creepy so let's hold on
here's what i tweeted
everyone is saying defund the police and
biden goes and picks kamala
and it's a it's a meme image of the thin
blue line flag
with kamala's head edited onto onto like
with a cop
uniform wait but she wasn't was she a
cop i thought she was just no she's like
a lawyer she's yeah she's a prosecutor
right right okay okay so the the meme
from the left is that kamala is a cop
and there's there's actually a lot to
break down you so so again joe biden
picks kamala harris
and although this is a joke you can see
her laughing as she arrests a little
black girl and then she's laughing and
back in the corner it's a thin blue line
flag it is this this image is a joke
there's a really good point cassandra
fairbanks made she's a conservative
writer
journalist she said republicans and
conservatives should not be a target
you know attacking kamala harris based
on law and order
because she was i don't want to say she
was tough on crime
what's the appropriate word what's like
an uh how do you describe someone as
wielding an iron fist
and crushing the will of the people uh
uh
slave owners desp despot desperate
despotic very much despotic she was
despotic
yeah she uh she was like separating
parents from their kids
and laughing about it she was arresting
people on you know
pot charges and then when asked about it
she joked about how her family smoked
and her family got mad about it
so yeah yeah here's what's funny the
left hates her because she's a cop
and the right hates her because she's
well for a lot of reasons
for one she's trying to adopt a bunch of
actually like very far left radical
positions and she's flip-flopped she has
no real positions
they've called her like um i don't know
like a pro
what do they call her a moderate
pragmatist never i haven't heard that
yeah yeah they're like just recently
when when biden announced her they're
like she's a moderate pragmatist and now
you've got the left and the right
agreeing they're saying things like
if if you mean that she's made no real
decisions other than
floating far-left policy and then not
committing to it and that that's
moderate
she's doing nothing other than having a
horrible track record
and trying to make it seem like all the
horrifying things she's done in her
career
are in fact all mistakes it was a
mistake from other people
when when she didn't want the dna tested
to free the innocent man from death row
yeah that accident accident and and when
her office
argued that people should put uh
parolees should not be eligible because
they needed cheap labor to go fight
fires
that that was all just it's all a
mistake and when she was separating you
know parents from their kids
and then what the democrats complaining
about trump doing it even though it's
happening on the obama administration
once again just all just a big mistake
you know what
okay i'll accept all that kamala makes
too many mistakes
therefore she's probably not fit to be
you know vp that's fair
so so we have this story this is like
the the big analysis
bp i'm sorry vidin vp finalist bp
say vidin i said i said i said bp
bp viden bp viden biden
vp finalists praise kamala harris
trump campaign jumps at biden pick as
democrats rally behind the california
senator
so here we go here's susan rice her
statement i warmly congratulate senator
kamala herrera
always pronounce her name wrong joe
biden's principled and responsible
leadership is what america urgently
needs i'm sorry i can't read this
i'm seeing too many posts from
progressives and black lives matter
people
who are like you've got racist joe biden
with cop
cop mala harris yep so what
it makes no sense they're trying they're
trying to court the far left
so they went for one of the most
detestable people he could have chosen
yeah that's why people thought he
wouldn't really go through with it oh i
thought you were talking
about biden at first there oh well i
mean he is detestable
yes i know and racist very openly and
right
caught many many many times throughout
his long
long career in government
he needs to be outed so here we have
oh gosh this we have uh uh wait wait i
gotta i gotta start from
hopefully i didn't spoil it yeah this is
great the principled the principled and
honorable
mr sean king no how dare you
i don't even like your sarcasm tim no
take it back all right all right all
right thank you i was gonna make the
joke
because sean king has this tweet from
2018 where he said
i'll be frank and tell you two democrats
that i am 99
sure i won't be supporting primarily
because of their dismal history on
criminal justice reform
over the course of their entire careers
joe biden
and kamala harris wow they both helped
build and advance
mass incarceration wait what did he
actually
did he actually tweet something that i
agree with yep
wow there's a meme wow there's a very
funny meme
and it is joe biden and he's grabbing
the shoulders of
kamala harris and smiling and they're
both looking at each other's eyes and it
says
it says uh biden harris because not
enough of you are in prison
wow wow yup well hold on hold on look at
this so we have this tweet from sean
king
so for the record this was two years ago
this is two years ago
i was i was joking when i said the
honorable in principle because of his
his next tweet from today that's it for
me
i'm incredibly proud to see a brilliant
black woman and hbcu grad chosen as vice
presidential nominee
i've done political work my whole life
it's rarely thing things dreams are
it's rarely things dreams are made of
kamala harris is the most progressive vp
nominee in american history
yeah shawn's done wow wait a minute i
gotta go back
can i go back how do i do it can you oh
yeah go back
[Laughter]
she's so progressive by building and
advancing mass incarceration wow
well done sean king well done
sean king is the is the epitome of so
yes and and this is a tweet uh from
death2tyrants84 on twitter i want to
give credit where credit is due
is the epitome it's like this dude's
opinion changes like every other day
but you don't you don't you know why it
worked you know why it works it works
because
not everybody sees every post from him
right yeah think about it it's very
clever
if you if you started tweeting out
things like you know trump is bad
then he started tweeting at things trump
is good peop the right will retweet the
trump is good and the left will reach
the trump is bad you'll get both
interesting i'm kidding it wouldn't
really work that way but i wonder how it
is that this works with for for sean
king
so now we're going to play a game it's
called um reading the news
where we look at the news about kamala
harris isn't that the same thing we do
every night tim
right right right but i mean like we're
going to go back in time
join me on a time machine as we go and
look at the record of kamala harris
and then we throw up in our models a
little bit the first thing i have to do
and
and lydia uh highlighted this i didn't
believe it was true if
what if i were to tell you that kamala
actually means something
in finnish i'm sure it does it does
and what do all of you think it means if
i said it meant something like
noble would you believe me nope probably
not how about
how about charming um
i don't know i don't know how about just
simply credible
no no okay well you would be correct
because how what if i told you it meant
horrible you know what i i think she's a
horrible person
so so maybe i didn't believe this
it literally does it it says horrible
okay so so so lydia posted this on
twitter i didn't believe it i credited
it to twitter itself because i went to
the lincoln project and they were like
oh we're going to endorse camelot they
just said the word camela
and it said translate this word so i was
like what the heck and i and then i
remembered after i did it because it
says translate from
finnish and then it said horror word is
horrible i did not believe yes
i was like haha funny joke yeah it's
great so i pulled up
translate.google.com and you go to
finish you type in kamala
and it says horrible and terrible awful
ghastly dreadful abysmal appalling
shocking
there's a terrific in there all right
appalling chronic
grim atrocious infernal
wow i mean if you if you hold a man
that could be proven innocent because of
dna
just because you want your your record
your you know whatever she you know she
was a attorney at the time or a
prosecutor
so she wanted her record to be high like
yeah she's got her prosecution record
well he was he was proven innocent the
court forced you to do it
she is a horrible infernal woman
infernal
like like of hell demonic to do that to
an innocent person
dude her name literally means horrible i
mean it's in finnish
yeah i wonder if my name means anything
any other language we'll have to look it
up people are going to be like tim means
like horse crap in swahili or something
well it does now tim
you just did it so so it's so we we got
to do this we got to do this we're this
is the special uh
kamala kamala we're doing a
what's what's what's what's the right
word i'm thinking of like we're looking
at her history
and a tribute yes almost
like a mini a mini deep dive into her
horrendous past
well what i was trying to say is like
you know you know when you go to those
award ceremonies and it plays like that
that
celine dion song highlight reel oh good
yeah and it shows like all the
highlights of their career and then they
give you like a retirement award or
something
sure congratulations kamala the kevin
cooper case
in february california governor gavin
newsom ordered new dna testing in the
1983 murder case of kevin cooper
cooper came within hours of execution in
o4
after being charged the murders of an
adult couple and two children harris
opposed the testing when she was the
state's attorney general
she has since said she supports dna
testing and encouraged newsome to
approve cooper's request
she did not offer specifics on why she
did not approve the testing during her
tenure
i mean i have some theories perhaps
perhaps it's because she's just i don't
know awful where
there's so many articles i got to try
and figure out which one there we go
here it is the daily beast
kamala harris's ag office tried to keep
inmates locked up for cheap labor
man that's i'm gonna say it that's
slavery
yeah that's not a joke right what were
you saying about what kanye said yeah
kanye
made a mistake oh not too like a little
while ago i remember how long ago
he said something about rep abolishing
the 13th amendment yeah
and that's what banned slavery and
everybody started going like oh no
kanye's unwell
no no kanye meant we have to basically
reform it because people don't realize
i think it's the 13th it's the 13th
right i believe right it's context
he was talking about a specific line in
that
13th amendment which was saying no
slavery
you can't force people to work unless
exactly right well go ahead do you have
it here
so i pulled it up it says 13th amendment
neither slavery nor involuntary
servitude
except as a punishment for crime aware
of the party shall have been duly
convicted
shall exist within the united states or
any place subject to their jurisdiction
boom that's what kanye was talking about
he was like
yo we got to get rid of this he's right
absolutely
i do not like the idea like we we our
our prison system is
not making people's lives better nope
it's just
sweeping the problem under the rug and
then exploiting people for cheap labor
and you know who made that worse
joe biden did in multiple different
different
bills that he wrote himself now we got
uh kamala kamala kama la kamala
yeah is that it okay yeah she she says
she says think of the word comma
c-o-m-a-l-a all right so camella
yeah carmelo carmelo
however the fins pronounce it so
horrible horrible harris
horrible horrible hair that's a good one
it's catchy i like it wow
that's really good horrible harris it's
illiterate no you don't let's have that
trend people
it's thank you f the fins huh yeah you
know
i'm actually i'm actually a part finish
hey so you're welcome
take pride and you just coined
you know how trump does like sleepy joe
and love energy
and sleepy joe and horrible harris
little marco yeah
i'm sorry but it's sleepy creepy joe
yeah i agree sleepy creepy joe and
horrible harris yes
the funny thing is like you weren't
doing it to make fun of her that's
literally what her name translates i
know that so it's well that's my quick
wit
at work there tim well no you were just
speaking finnish
yeah there we go that's her name well no
then it would have been kamala harris
and you're translating
and harris just there's no word for it
to finish so yeah i actually did some
experiments in the translate where i was
like
i write i wrote kamala is horrible and
it says kamala on kamala in finnish
so she really did this now here's the
funny thing
she tried arguing after the fact that it
was it was lawyers in her office and she
had no idea
i was shocked that they did this shut up
so she couldn't control
people in her own office and we're
supposed to expect her to be able to be
the vice president
of the united states yeah when she can't
control the people in her own office
doing things that are
are horrendous to say to be light on it
and to be getting out of here like the
worst she i mean i didn't i didn't like
her anyway
and and i would say in terms of trump's
appointees
and the mistakes he's made the worst we
see with him is he's fired everybody
that's true you know she she had him do
their thing not that i think trump made
good choices
particularly with bolton i mean he made
some mistakes man
so you know i try to be careful
especially looking at say
you know kamala harris joe biden and if
they do something like common harris's
track record is
trash yep so i wonder why we you know i
i don't hear a whole lot about you know
mike pence's track record
you know what i mean i think it'd be
fair to bring up but honestly
nobody's talking about it that's true
because because there's nothing there
well i don't know much about penn state
to be honest he was he was the governor
of indiana he was yeah
there's criticisms over like some of his
policies
okay but it was a long time ago and so i
think it would be fair to be like okay
you know we could compare the two but
i think the challenge right now is that
conservatives and progressives are
unified
in their disdain for this woman horrible
harris yeah
and mike pence i gotta be honest is kind
of uh
milk toast yeah milk toast he's not
really but like
you know kind of yeah like you know
it's it's really interesting a lot of
vps like
i'm not saying this be disrespectful to
anybody but tim kaine
may it was like he's like you know
vanilla yogurt yeah it's like
you know what is that mike pence i feel
similarly star of the show you were
talking about
uh bill barr the other day about how he
just kind of seemed boring
no no that's different okay yeah like
like bill barr man
you know the way he talks you know his
his retorts his funny
like his wit okay he's he's he's cut and
dry is a better way to put it okay i i
use boring in a sense where it's like
he's not you know you you laugh when you
watch the guy when when he got asked at
that hearing
they were like you know the the priests
and the bishops condemned this action
and he goes was that before or after we
put the fire out
yeah that was like but what i mean is he
didn't like snap and you know
you didn't say no no we put out a fire
no he just had a dry quick wit it was
great
tim kaine was like what
like what is it no he was just weird
like did he ever say
anything i don't remember anything i
don't know any words he's ever said
so you know to be fair like i think you
know
moving forward as especially as it
pertains to
weighing the options fairly i'll be
looking into
you know how has trump hired people as
biden hi i'm sorry as as
pence taking action because i'll
criticize kamal all chris has everybody
but i got to tell you man kamala harris
is a higher profile individual than mike
pence's yep
mike pence was uh governor of indiana
again right yeah yeah okay
correct but even in that regard it's
like they try to go after pence
periodically but he's
not he doesn't have that kind of
public recognition in the sense where
people love talking about them the way
they do kamala harris
kamala harris can't pronounce her name
and i think it's because of stories like
this
like you know tried to keep inmates
locked up for cheap labor
and she can give any excuse she wants
about oh no the people i hired were
doing you know the people appointed in
my office were doing these horrible
things like okay well the buck stops
with you man well they were doing
horrible things because you're horrible
harris
so it makes sense in my mind i'll tell
you what man we've got let me let me see
if i can find these uh
there's a bunch of stories here i just i
just pulled this one up my favorite is
look at this one
oh okay well i'm sure we're gonna talk
about it later about how she was calling
out joe biden for being
oh i got it uber racist waiting for that
hammer to drop okay okay
this one here it says uh camila kamala
horrible harris
laughed about jailing parents over
truancy it's not funny
this is from it's not funny at all a
year a year and a half ago it was single
parents
yeah not just parents she was hitting up
single parents who their kids didn't go
to school it's like how does she know
what they were going through
didn't matter your kids are truant so
they're we're coming after you
this is insane i just i found out about
this today too this is crazy
let's read a little bit they say for
progressives there are good reasons to
be suspicious of the idea
that former prosecutors make good
politicians the u.s has the highest
incarceration rate in the world
and its criminal punishment system
disproportionately punishes poor people
and people of color
prosecutors have a leading role in
sustaining this injustice
in part because they tend to view
prisons as solutions to social problems
i agree with a lot of that sentiment i
think we have a horrible prison system
and i think we need to fix it and we
have a lot of cultural issues too i
think we need to get to the root of a
lot of these
you know criminal actions and issues
substance abuse etc
that world view is fully on display in
recently
unearthed video footage of kamala harris
defending her decision to criminally
prosecute parents
for their children's truancy in the
video
taken to the commonwealth club in 2010
when harris was district attorney of san
francisco
harris says that because a child is
going without an education it's
tantamount to a crime
she decided to treat parents with
absentee children as criminals
with what was the crime that she pinned
in on truancy
how is that on the parents she's an
authoritarian desperate despotic
individual so
clearly it doesn't seem like she needs
the law if she's going to you know keep
people
in prison for cheap labor that's true
that was the tulsi gabbard thing
yeah for most of you i've seen it ripped
her apart for that everybody's saying
just keep playing tulsi gabbard's video
on loop of her just
ripping it apart dude i tell you man
when that moment dropped the debates
when tulsi did it
i was like standing and i was clapping
everybody was cheering and like
high-fiving
yes conservative and progressive alike
were like yeah
harris cheerfully recounts the story of
sending an attorney from her office to
intimidate a
homeless single mother whose children
were missing school
she smiles as she recalls how she
instructed her subordinates to look
really mean
so the mother would take the threat of
jail seriously
in separate footage harris mocks those
on the left who say things like build
schools not jails
and put put more money into education
not prisons
suggesting they are a naive sloganers
who do not understand
crime prevention wow here we see the
limits of prosecutorial mindset
like the old slogan when all you have is
a hammer everything looks like a nail
when all you have is the ability to
bring criminal charges everything looks
like a crime and there you go man
her we got we got so much we got so much
to go through here her horrible record
is coming back to haunter all of these
stories has been popping up nonstop and
everybody knew
this was going to happen the choice joe
biden made
i i'm sorry man i think i think my brain
snapped as soon as i heard oh yeah and i
was like
that's it there is a grand conspiracy
among the democrats to secretly get
trump elected
yep how stupid do they have to be every
step of the way it's like in sports
they're doing a rebuild year
they're rebuilding it's true
you're not wrong i know so i said it oh
but that feels like i gotta revel in
that for a little bit when you when you
say i'm not wrong
well no no but but take a deep breath
this is an important thing people think
they know you know harris is out yep she
got roasted she's done biden is retiring
so they're like we we have to have
somebody
they know they're going to lose they
have to have somebody
well who can they spare you know they
don't want to use a young up-and-comer
who might become a star
yep so they go for people who are
unpopular or about to retire
yeah think about this man this is this
is so so hilarious it's like
they they chose a guy on the verge of
retirement
essentially coming out of retirement and
they chose someone everybody hates
it was basically them saying like here's
the bottom of the barrel
you can have that and we'll focus on
2024 jack jack murphy
he was a guest on on the show like four
or five months ago
like he was the first guy was he the
first guest yeah i think yeah i think so
so he tweeted out he goes if you if
you're gonna lose an election to trump
you're finished
the democrats know trump has a good
chance of winning this election
therefore they will not run
any serious candidates in this election
that's why this entire thing is a
throwaway race
and he's absolutely right i was like yep
that's it nailed it
there they know they're going to lose
they know trump's going to win
landslide thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm if you want to
catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you